so let's get to what you're investing in
today and how you're looking at
investing in this crazy market market is
going bonkers right now
um you must be seeing a bunch of markups
in your
uh portfolio what's what's going well
for you i know you were in career karma
i hear that's going really well
yes it is i mean this is all stuff that
we we predicted
so it's it's it feel i think from the
outside it feels like oh my goodness i
can't believe all these companies
especially companies led by
underrepresented founders are doing so
well uh
pre last may and post last may
it's starting to it's like popcorn you
know it's like i can't wake up without
some sort of
email saying uh you know your your
convertible note is converting
to this and you know we'll announce in
two months or whatever and
it's just it's great it's exactly where
we want to be
career karma's exciting um part explain
what they do um and why you invested
they match
uh uh people with coding camps for the
most part and other type of tech camps
um and so instead of trying to compete
with coding camps they say let's be the
bridge to coding camps and
so they they have a friend on both sides
and i think i think that's really
exciting obviously it's um working and
uh ruben is is a fantastic uh ceo to
that company
yeah it's it's over a hundred thousand
people from what i understand now and
you can go in there and find
all these people talking about their
careers and then actually
it's kind of like yelp in a way where
like you get a read on which of these
schools
what people actually think of the
schools before you yeah take the isa
deal
income sharing agreement uh et cetera
and man it looks like it's doing
really well what what else is popping
what what what are the popcorn is
popping from yeah
it's so weird i mean this is your first
time going through the cycle
yeah so if this is your first time
seeing it get like red hot like this
yeah but it's again i we predicted it
and so we're
we're not like freaking out internally
we're just like great this is
because we just as many things that are
going well we also have to put out fires
and we also have to
work with those companies every day and
we've been doing that as if we put in a
million dollars each right that's
kind of been the secret of it is to be
really steady along the way
so this is exciting for the founders and
for the companies but
um we're on track here you know partake
foods is another one that popped
popped into my head just now because
they're all over target and and um i
think whole foods and
but definitely target and targets asking
for more and more and more
uh which is hard to do is to be in that
position
and they just have an incredible lineup
of things in the next two months that
are about to to be announced and it's
just
incredible and i remember meeting denise
and what was it 2017 i think that was a
really good year for us but
2017 and she was saying that
you know she had this coca-cola
background as an executive
she she knew she had a daughter who had
the pain point of
needing allergy free food and vegan and
this and that
and just nobody was biting nobody was
really listening to her
and um now you look at it and you and
and i know from
personal experience her her latest round
was incredibly competitive
like like silly or competitive you know
some of these rounds where
it's not like can i get the last 50 000
it's like oh we're
like 400 x over subscribe so we're only
taking 100 right 100x
it's really interesting um and then they
make
cookies and baked goods that are safe
for people with allergies and have great
you know superfoods in them for people
who don't know and you can go see it at
partakefoods.com
i'm noticing this trend a lot people are
really getting into food
direct to consumer food and direct to
consumer
products um which i think a lot of our
contemporaries are like uh direct to
consumer
it doesn't scale like yeah it doesn't
scale the same as software what are your
thoughts on that
still really difficult to do we just
have we just
wherever we are like we are agnostic and
so
it doesn't matter if it's a food company
a toilet paper company
or which by the way is doing really well
bippy
or a satellite company what we do
is we bet on the founders and we bet on
what the secret sauce that they have and
that unfair advantage that they have
and it's almost like they could be doing
anything they could have chosen any line
of work
but we bet on their ability to and their
and that chip on their shoulder that
they have
that is what's like really appealing and
so
yes it's very difficult to have a cpg
company
direct to consumer at any point
but we just happen to have found some
people who are just kicking butt another
good example of that is curl mix they're
raising a reg
reg cf right now for the 5 million
they're already i think they're about to
hit 3 million
they just started last week and i met
them in 2017 when they were mixing
uh hair products in their kitchen and
doing less than 10 000 a month in
revenue
and now they did 6 million last year
2020 and then they'll do
more than that they're already like over
this year wow
yeah it is um we have
three or four investments in direct to
consumer the sip which is doing
champagne
tasting uh boxes nude bar and
um ruby love which is doing
undergarments and
all three of them doing great in terms
of growth and
a little getting a little crowded in
that space in terms of buying ads and
trying to acquire customers so many
people competing
so i've been thinking about that space
and we we i basically made a two
i mean one of those four quadrant
matrixes and i was like x-axis how
unique is the product y-axis
how growth-minded what's the growth
scale of the founder and i said
if we're going to do any of these it has
to be like really in that top right a
really unique differentiated product
and the founder really loves doing
growth because if you don't love doing
growth and you're
trying to sell toilet paper or underwear
or
hair products whatever it is it's just
not going to work right i mean yeah
it's good you're going to it's going to
die on the vine no matter how good the
product is you need to have marketing
there
what do you think about valuations right
now are you seeing valuations go
way up um well we were always
always discounted so i'm seeing them
kind of catching up
to what had been quote unquote normal in
the past
about three years ago and now now uh
black people and women are being
so bold as to say what they're worth and
uh
you know so i think i'm seeing it from a
different purview i'm not seeing the
the inflated uh ones you know there's
some
um exception to that every every time i
you know to the rule
but by and large it's okay now and
we got in so early and so many of these
companies and and still do
um and and people the more we the more
we work with people as you know jason
this is what you've built
the more you work the more founders say
that they love working with you
and then more people really want you in
the cap table and so they're
they're saying you know what is it what
does it take to get you in
yeah that is the amazing thing that can
happen when you get past 50 or 100
investments when you get into year six
seven or eight as you and i both have
um you you start to have your founders
are now marketing you and people want
you on the cap table so
you're not chasing deals as much as
sorting through them
how do you tell me about the composure
of the team now
how many people do you have and how many
deals do you have to sort through and i
also know you did your own
uh syndicate now so i want to get an
update on that and then just how do you
sort through all the inbound
and is there a moment in time you most
want to meet somebody
when they have an idea when they have a
mock-up when they have a business plan
when they have
five customers 50 customers tell me
about your goldilocks zone
we have seven people officially on the
team with a couple of freelancers who
are very helpful
um we have three four czech riders three
decision makers uh for now so it's
myself it's christy pitts who is a
partner
formerly at verizon ventures came in
four years ago i think
brittany davis formerly a founder
herself she went to
harvard business school and she's worked
at village capital and angel
hashtag angels and um she
came in about three years ago and then
we have chacho valladez
who is a principal and so the partners
can make autonomous investing decisions
chacho has uh co-led two deals in the
past year
so he's more and more going to in that
direction
and we just we just work as a as a unit
usually and
a lot of times i will bring in companies
and and ask
the team to take a look at it but for
the most part um
we're working as a group and then we
have um
i have a arlen was here team at
backstage because
the inbound that i get is just out of
this world uh
again you would relate to that so we
just have that going
um and where do i want to meet
so we have we get thousands of
applications a year
we have an application process that
makes things easier and we
we also uh we're going to be introducing
a program that is
you can think of it as a as an
apprenticeship program
you can think of it in some ways like a
scouting program
some ways like a uh like i said an
apprenticeship or
an internship program but that will be
kind of a new iteration that you'll see
later this year
because we just get so much inbound now
and our team is the smallest it's been
in years which is on purpose
and so i like personally so everybody
has their own tastes and
you know ask everyone else too because
it's varied
um i still like to i still
love the earth like the early exciting
part of things that's how i
i love coming up with ideas and like
sparking things and catalyzing people at
the right time
so um i need you to have done some stuff
like i need traction even if it's not
like
you have a bunch of money that you've
raised or that you know
you're the the you know going into your
fourth year at stanford or anything like
that but just something what have you
done
with with very little uh if that's the
case
and today i may have said this last time
but
it's very strong it feels very strong
right now it's like if you if it would
take me a decade or more
to do it myself to figure out what
you're doing myself then i'm
very interested because that means i can
live longer through you
kind of you know live bigger through
yeah
so instead of kind of helps me kind of
just decipher between
the the vitamin peel thing or medicine
thing it's like is it is it kind of okay
and mediocre and like cool but like
what is it really gonna do at the end of
the day or is it is it
gonna change the world possibly and that
i just feel that way the older i get